aproximadamente una vez al mes se
desarrolla una serie de eventos
denominada ciclo menstrual para preparar
el cuerpo de una mujer para el embarazo
niveles cambiantes de sustancias
químicas naturales en el torrente
sanguíneo denominadas hormonas controlan
estos eventos los órganos reproductores
afectados por estas hormonas incluyen la
vagina
el cuello uterino
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
los ovarios producen dos hormonas
principales denominadas estrógeno y
progesterona
a medida que el nivel de estrógeno
empieza a aumentar la mucosidad espesa
normal del cuello uterino adelgaza
el estrógeno también activa otras
hormonas para que uno de los ovarios
libere un óvulo este proceso se denomina
ovulación
si una mujer mantiene relaciones
sexuales durante este periodo las
células reproductivas masculinas
denominadas espermatozoides pueden pasar
a través de la mucosidad más delgada
para fertilizar un óvulo en el útero el
estrógeno engrosa el endometrio y lo
prepara para recibir un óvulo
fertilizado
el aumento de los niveles de
progesterona provoca que las glándulas
de la pared liberen un líquido que
alimenta el óvulo fertilizado
también hace que la mucosidad adelgazada
del cuello uterino se vuelva a expresar
lo que evita el paso de los
espermatozoides
si no se fertilizó un óvulo los niveles
de estrógeno y de progesterona empiezan
a disminuir
esta disminución en los niveles
hormonales provoca la menstruación un
proceso en el cual el útero elimina el
revestimiento de tejido interno y la
sangre a través de la vagina
un dispositivo intrauterino diu es un
método de control de natalidad que
consta de un dispositivo en forma de t
flexible y suave con un hilo fino en el
extremo
existen dos tipos de dispositivos
intrauterinos diu hormonal
y diu de cobre
para evitar el embarazo el médico coloca
un diu dentro del útero de la mujer con
el hilo colgando dentro de la vagina
ambos tipos de diu hacen que el
endometrio se inflamen levemente lo que
libera células inmunes y sustancias
químicas que matan los espermatozoides
los diu hormonales contienen un tipo
sintético de progesterona denominado
levonorgestrel
el levonorgestrel principalmente evita
un embarazo es pesando la mucosidad
dentro del cuello uterino lo que evita
que los espermatozoides entren en el
útero
también evita el engrosamiento del
endometrio de manera que es menos
probable que reciba un óvulo fecundado
aproximadamente un mes después de que se
coloca el diu es probable que el médico
programe un examen para constatar que
aún esté en el lugar correcto es
probable que también le enseñé a la
mujer cómo revisar su vientre consultas
ella debe sentir el hilo dentro de la
vagina
según el tipo se puede dejar colocado un
diu durante un periodo de entre 3 y 10
años las mujeres pueden solicitar la
extracción del dio a sus médicos en
cualquier momento y por cualquier motivo
incluso el deseo de tener hijos
un dispositivo intrauterino diu es uno
de los métodos de control de natalidad
más efectivos
los diu tienen una eficacia de más de un
99 por ciento en la prevención de
embarazos
esto significa que menos de una década
sin mujeres quedará embarazada cada año
se utilizan un diu y lo revisan con
frecuencia para comprobar si está
colocado correctamente
sin embargo tiene una eficacia de sólo
un 97% si no se controla que el diu esté
colocado correctamente
para obtener más información sobre
cualquier método de control de natalidad
consulte a su médico